[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Welcome back to
Inter Sections.
We're now beginning
panel number two
which will be moderated by
Dr. Erik Ghenoiu who will now
come to the podium and tell
you about the panel so welcome
back.
[APPLAUSE]
- So panel two--
we now want to open up the
discussion to questions
of the relationship of the
city to our concept of nature
and the role that
technology can play
in mediating and reinforming
that relationship.
So we're all familiar with the
kind of ecological problems
and technological
opportunities that
are faced by the contemporary
city in that the city kind
of creates and
conditions around it.
We talk about it all the time.
But within that, we
mean not only kind of
like pollution and
the what's happening
to natural landscapes,
but also the kind
of social issues of social
justice and long term
viability of the
planet that's become
kind of a touchstone for modern
debates about the environment.
But in relationship
to that, I think
something that helps us maybe
move a little further forward
in that discussion
is an emerging
debate from many fields
calling into question
the terms with which we
discuss these things.
So I think of people
like cultural critics
and social scientists
who question
the idea that our effects
on the environment
are all kind of one thing,
but rather kind of identifying
the specific actions,
even historically,
the kind of role of capitalism.
The specific and more
recent and taking apart
the package of man's
impact on the world
into the kind of
political realities
that generated that impact.
And I think of people like the
philosophers and environmental
theorists who call into
question the very idea of nature
as something that's
not real that's.
That was always
a kind of conceit
of a pure pristine thing
that we can be other than
and that we can kind of
hold up on a pedestal
that kind of frees us from
the dirty responsibility
of participation and a critical
engagement with an environment
of which we are, after
all, also a part.
And so thinking in
that kind of tradition,
I think the question that
we want to look at today
is what does it mean in light
of these kind of grand problems
that we all face and in
light of a kind of critique
of the idea of the
natural and what role
man's actions, both
cultural and technological,
can play in relationship to it?
What role is there for critical
practice in different fields?
And so to ask that question, we
have our distinguished guests.
So in order that
they will speak,
we have Dilip da Cunha,
the architect and planner
who's really one of
the leading voices
to think about the relationship
of natural and cultural
landscapes in much more
than just an ecological way,
but in many ways.
Anna Schuleit Haber,
the artist, who's
explored a lot of questions
around the meaning
of our relationship
to the environment.
If the urban is always the
sort of relationship of us
to these physical spaces
and places and memories,
then kind of exploring
the implications
of that that can be kind
of carried further forward.
And then third, we'll hear from
Anja Thierfelder and Matthias
Schuler who work kind
of across the kind
of technological relationship
with climate and nature
both on the kind of massive
scale of real advising
of huge projects
that are going on,
but also in the most aesthetic
and critically informed
kind of refined ways, as
well, through their art
and architecture installations.
So without further ado, let me
hand over the podium to Dilip.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you very much, Erik,
and thank you for inviting me.
When we see water doing
what water is doing today,
I think it is time to not
just think differently.
It's not just time to
see things differently.
I think it is time to see
different things so I'm
going to make sort of lay
out a possibility, perhaps
a bold possibility.
I'm going to pause at, actually,
the possibility that we have
got nature wrong to
begin with or perhaps,
we've got the wrong nature.
Now I'm going to share with you
actually two projects that we
see here on the
left and the right.
Projects each opening
the possibility
of a different nature.
Now, it won't follow
this structure,
but if I just move to the next
slide, what I'm going to do
is actually I'm going to
have convention on the left
and I'm going to have
possibility on the right.
So first, Bombay.
I know Sooni's sort of
pointed out the fact,
actually, that Mumbai is
associated with the Shiv Sena
and it has cultural
connotations.
I mean, the way
I'm using it, you
will see is the
possibility that maybe we
can see a different place.
And so what I am
suggesting, actually,
is that Bombay is the island
city that the British saw
and that we still
continue to see
as an island and a
city that is an island.
But Mumbai, opening the
possibility that Mumbai
is an estuary.
And what does that do,
actually, to planning
and the shift in thinking.
The way in which
we see an estuary--
I mean, we know of an
estuary as the mouth
of a river like a delta, except
that the sea comes in as much
as the water goes out.
But in a delta, its more the
river that dominates the sea.
But what I want
to suggest here is
that in India during
the monsoons when water
is everywhere, water
doesn't have time
to find lines on the map
and so it just flows off
and so you have an estuary
all along the coast.
So it's a meeting ground,
actually, of land and sea,
if you will.
So on the one hand, you see
and plan and you see and plan,
you draw a line.
I mean, that's how we got
the coast and the coast
is actually solidified
into the strong line
as you can see in this
trajectory of maps.
On the other hand, an
estuary is open to the sea
and so it calls for
seeing in section.
It calls for seeing depth.
It calls for seeing
actually in time
so there's a rhythm, actually,
as opposed to this divide.
So on the one hand, we
have marginalized the sea
by drawing that line and
so you have land and sea.
But then you've also
marginalized the monsoon
because then the monsoon
comes as a visitor,
visits land and goes on.
That's the way we see it.
So this is a place
where I would like
to see the monsoon as a
resident, not as a visitor.
So what does it mean,
actually, to shift our mindset
to an estuary that is
home to the monsoon
and not to the place
for the monsoon
to be an annual visitor because
in that particular role,
actually, the
monsoon is becoming
more and more a kind
of enemy and you're
waiting with anxiety
for the monsoon
because it brings flood--
that's what it does.
Then on the one hand, I
mean the convention actually
could suggest instead of viewing
and plan, you see land use.
You see land use, you see
land divides and so the island
that you saw there
becomes a smaller island
and then it divides
into smaller places
and that's how you plan--
planning is in plan.
It's not just
foresight, it's actually
comes with a particular
perception and reading
of ground and terrain that
may stem from geography,
but then, perhaps, geography
is problematic to begin with.
So what happens, actually,
when you see in section
and you begin to see
there are practices?
You don't see land uses,
you see practices in time.
And so when you get the boat
pulled up in the monsoon,
you get activities
in Bombay that
operate actually on
the basis of time,
not on the basis of space.
And so that's what you
see in an estuary--
at least I want to
suggest that that's
what you see in an estuary.
So what do you have,
actually, are two paradigms.
On the one hand,
you have a flood
in drain paradigm where
you're actually draining water
off the land because
that's the divide that you
[? had educated ?] into because
you separated water from land,
flowing, draining,
et cetera, flooding.
It's a flood.
There's nothing
but water crossing
a line that were drawn.
Flood-- if anybody tells you
it's natural, don't believe it.
It's not.
It's water crossing a line
that has been drawn so it's not
about where you draw
the line, it's the fact
that you do draw a line.
On the other hand, you
have a whole soak paradigm
and an estuary, actually,
where water is held.
And so when I hold rain,
it's very different way
of actually seeing.
I don't see flowing.
I don't see draining.
I don't see rivers,
actually, I just see rain.
It requires a certain
dryness to see rivers
and I want to suggest--
I think I'm just going to
pass over this because this
is what happens, actually, in
a project where possibility
defies convention.
We look differently,
we see differently,
and we draw differently and
then we appropriate the ground
differently--
I won't have time
to actually spend
on the details of this
project, but you will find it
in various articles--
but walking by
anchors, holdings,
things that live lightly
in a ground in an estuary
rather than this master
planning that just
fails again and again.
So if I had to generalize
from this paradigm
now into what I really
mean, actually, perhaps
more universally, I would
suggest that taking [INAUDIBLE]
cycle, water cycle, that we
have actually chosen on the left
by convention to inhabit one
particular moment in time
in the hydrologic cycle when
water can be held in a place
so it's the realm of flows.
So I had to look at the water
cycle as going this way--
the flow formation,
evaporation, cloud formation,
and precipitation--
we have chosen this moment
to construct a reality
and we made all the other
moments of water ephemeral.
And so rain is a
visitor, snow's a visitor
and they're not residents.
I want to suggest,
actually, that there's
a possibility of actually
changing the moment in time
in which we construct reality,
in which we construct nature.
So if rivers are not
natural, perhaps rain is.
And then you get a
completely different ground.
So what does it mean,
actually, to design
with ubiquitous
wetness as opposed
to the land water divide?
And would that suggest a
completely different set
of disciplines by which we
learn a different understanding
of the world, really?
So this I suggest for the
ground of the monsoon,
but I also suggest that it is
a possibility across the world
that we choose a
different moment in which
to construct reality and to
make other moments ephemeral.
How much time do I have?
Oh, it's here.
OK, I do have time.
So on the one hand,
what I'm suggesting is
that our nature is by choice--
that nature is not a given.
This is a subject of
study for the last five,
six years now and it's turned
into a book that suggests that
rivers are inventions and
that they had been made over
the years, actually, by literacy
that has separated water from
land that cannot be
assumed to be natural.
So what does that mean?
And you know, it
goes back, actually,
to the school of Miletus in
the sixth century BC where
this act of drawing the line
and separating water from land
was a necessity, actually,
for the Greeks of the school
of Miletus and they imposed
it in a set of disciplines
across the world.
So you know Alfred
North Whitehead
is famous for saying
that all philosophy is
a footnote to Plato, but then
if you look at what Plato was
a footnote to,
we'll find that he
was a footnote to
the school of Miletus
and their laying
out of an Earth.
Some so material actually
came before philosophizing,
if you will, if I can sort of
make a kind of claim there.
So what I'm suggesting over
here is another moment,
another time, and
another nature.
Well, just to give you another
project, in coastal Virginia,
we're working
there on the coast.
So here I want to suggest,
actually, that on the one hand,
you have a coastline
where the water's coming
and we have been in
a community meeting
where people have been
to a drumbeat saying
water's coming, water's
coming because it is coming.
In Norfolk, they feel
the seas coming in,
but that's because we made the
sea an outsider and an enemy.
So what is this paradigm
that has actually
constructed that people have
this rising fear of the sea?
And I want to suggest,
actually, there's
a whole other way of looking
at this place at Norfolk
and really looking at the
tide-- you might know what
is tidewater
country which refers
to the whole of the
Southern Chesapeake.
So on the one hand, you have a
coastline that have been drawn
and it actually was drawn only
when the Europeans actually
arrived here.
It was a series
of frontiers that
came that came across and then
went across the United States,
but there was always a line
that began with the East
Coast of the United States.
And the further you went,
the more reinforced this line
became between land and sea.
And so there are only two
choices then one has over here
and that is either attack
the sea or defend or retreat,
I should say, defend
against a sea of retreat.
So you're talking
with levees, they're
talking about the
mouth of the Chesapeake
with gates and all kinds
of ideas like that.
Oh, and somebody
told me and they say,
I've got a solution for Norfolk.
Take all these people and
put them in West Virginia.
I mean, from that sense
of the retreat following,
this thing has its own
sort of absurdities.
But what we suggest
is turn the coast.
Instead of looking
at the line this way,
look at the line this way.
Turn the point, I should say.
Instead of joining
the points like that,
open the points this way so
that you allow the sea in.
And then what does that mean?
I mean you get a completely
different paradigm.
So here you have barriers
and gates and retreat
and then you have high
ground, low ground,
so water doesn't actually
flood, doesn't cross the line.
Water just rises and
falls and that's the way,
actually, the Indians
lived in the Mississippi
or the Native Americans lived
in the Mississippi as opposed
to this one where you
actually then have a levee
and you live across the line.
But this goes into all
deltas and it goes actually
to the coast, as well.
So you have a paradigm of
fingers of high ground.
It would be called fingers
of ground and on this side,
you have levee systems
like New Orleans,
but you might be a little
more intelligent today
and actually divide Norfolk into
a number of bowls, if you will.
So if one floods,
the other doesn't.
But this is actually
constructing risk.
And so what is a
system that one wants?
Does one want to define
risk in this manner
or actually allow for
resilience not to take place
and, in fact, I missed
that slide earlier on.
Yeah, here, where they talk
about two kinds of resilience--
one is a recovery
from disaster and one
is not getting to disaster
in the first place.
And it's difficult to
actually argue that,
but it's easy to
design it, if you will.
So what happens here?
This is just a project that
suggests how this can be done
and we do it in two
places, two sites.
What does it mean
down the coast?
How does one work with
communities in order to do it?
How does one do it over--
like I always say, it's taken us
500 years to get into the soup,
it will take us another
500 years to get out of it.
So why don't we start
with that structuring,
but it requires a completely
different mindset and approach
that goes down to, actually,
the way we understand
our disciplines.
So this just gives
you a sense, actually,
of how the project develops
and evolves over time
and how we can sort of
meet the sea in points,
like that, as opposed to a
line, like that, and accommodate
water treatment
systems with the sea.
There are many,
many different ways
by which we allowed
this meeting ground
to occur in a more open manner.
So you see, actually,
the existing condition
here on the left.
To some extent,
this is recovering
what we have lost by the
filling of our creeks
and the destruction
of high ground.
I mean, Boston is a
classic example, actually,
of the flattening of terrain
and now we're doing everything
to regret it now.
You What do we do to
recover our high grounds
and to recover creek systems
that were pooling systems,
not flowing systems-- pooling
systems with fantastic
ecologies which we
can recover, but it
means recovering low
ground and you can only
recover low ground if you start
reconstructing high ground.
So I won't go into how we
are doing it in Norfolk.
There are many ways
that we can and we've
established that possibility.
I think I've reached
the end of my show here.
And this is I dared to take on
Einstein a little bit here so I
say that we cannot solve
our problems with the same
thinking.
I mean, he said
the same thinking,
I'm saying you cannot solve the
problems with the same nature
that went into creating them.
So what I'm
suggesting is that we
got to start thinking of
another place, another time.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- It is such an
honor to be back.
I love this place
and its people and I
thank the staff so very
much for having organized
this conference with these
incredibly inspiring colleagues
of mine.
Thank you for being here.
I am going to give you a
glimpse of my creative process.
Some of the projects that touch
on urbanism, specifically,
and some that, perhaps, hope
to expand the concept of it.
My work often
begins with a site,
a setting that needs to be
explored, that can be wandered,
of which I then
become the wanderer.
They're public and
not so public sites.
I'm drawn to the
more hidden corners
of public life, the blurred
edges of our communities,
large and small.
At the Rhode Island School
of Design, I studied painting
and if you held
a gun to my head,
I would say that's what I am--
I am a painter--
but everything that I've
done since studying painting
and graduating as a
painter has sort of
explored the edges of
painting and wandered off
into larger media.
I had to accept painting
as a two dimensional medium
and wondered how that medium
would relate to the surrounding
world, it's outside sources.
So I came to my work as a
pedestrian with the wish
to somehow capture the
enormous architecture
I was interested in at that
time as a young student,
specifically
psychiatric hospitals,
through drawings and paintings.
From across the
overgrown lawn, I
recorded my walks using
them as my hand-drawn record
of my interaction with the site.
Based on my interest in
map reading and mapmaking,
they became a form of
remembered orientation in space.
And my first works were
a failing of painting
and that I realized
there's really no reason
to paint these buildings but to
collect what's already there,
to gather what's already there.
And passing through each
room in these institutions,
I would take a paint sample--
it was all lead paint.
So this is my walk through
the building in linear terms
from left to right.
And the larger boxes
are larger spaces,
the smaller ones, the square
ones, are patient cells.
In its widest sense, I'm
curious about the imprint
that the urban environment has
on us as its users, citizens,
and the members of
the communities--
how we navigate our environment,
how we make sense of it,
how we derive meaning
from it, and how
we give back meaning to it.
I found this place in outside
Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania.
This is the Dixmont
State Hospital--
the center of it, before
it was torn down--
and the oculus
that you see there
has, as Dorothea Dix, the
reformer of the 19th century
said, one of the most beautiful
views of North America.
The French philosopher
Gaston Bachelard
described the
motionless daydreamer
as experiencing an
immensity of being.
He said immensity
is within ourselves.
It is attached to a sort of
expansion of being that life
curbs and caution arrests,
but which starts again
when we were alone.
As soon as we become motionless,
we are dreaming in a world that
is a man's.
Indeed, immensity is the
movement of motionless man.
So my first project, one
that is I think breaking away
from urbanism, was
a daydream to me
and it was cited here at this
hospital, Northampton State
Hospital, with its
vast interiors,
hallways that would allow
a car to pass through.
It was a large scale
science specific sound voice
performance at
Northampton State Hospital
spanning 414,000 square feet
of connected space using
the hallways and rooms of
the abandoned structure.
Like the insides of an
instrument, a sound body,
this was my first
project that took me
beyond the parameters
of painting
clearly and placed me in a more
experimental and performative
realm.
It was a form of
architectural dreaming
without touching the building
at all because sound lives in it
and then disappears again.
I was able to work with
the entire building
without moving an inch
of it or any of it.
I realized the painting
was not large enough,
not inclusive enough.
Sound was the only
medium for me.
I thought I could animate
the entire architecture
without disturbing it,
interrupting it, reshaping
it, or reducing it.
So this was the set up we strung
thousands of feet of cable
through the building and
connected the entire hospital
with itself.
And this is the back wards.
This is where patients
used to be who were violent
and often there
for decades on end.
And the sound was meant to be
bounced through the building
by bouncing it off
a surface first.
We didn't let it get
out of the windows
right away, but rather
using the building
to take on its
color, it's solidity,
and changing the sound thereby.
The sound I chose was Johann
Sebastian Bach's Magnificat
because I had been a
choir girl and because I
love that piece of music
and because I remembered it
every time I was
in this building--
like a physical memory,
it came back to me.
So this is the
solarium it was called
in one of the easier units where
patients had small freedoms.
And then we invited
an unknown public
to come and listen to this.
The entire thing
was only 28 minutes.
It took four years
to do and we didn't
know who was going to come,
but the state hospital
was long closed and there was
no trespassing, of course,
and we broke the rules for that
one day for that one half hour
and thousands showed up.
This was in Northampton,
Massachusetts.
And I didn't let people
into the building
for, obviously,
liability reasons,
but I also didn't want
them to play haunted house.
I wanted them to give
the building its presence
and allow the building to sound.
And this is how some of
the people experienced it.
I went back to painting so
back to recording my walks
and I didn't know
how after doing
that, after connecting with an
entire community of volunteers,
sound engineers, politicians,
lobbyists, students,
I would then go back to
being a single painter.
And I decided that that's
just all I wanted to do,
but the next project was
a project which I'm just
going to show two slides of.
It was for the Massachusetts
Mental Health Center
here in Boston.
The same sort of building,
but very different.
50 years later, it closed
and Harvard Medical School
Department of Psychiatry
asked me to do the music again
and I decided I wasn't
going to do that--
that was site
specific, but I was
going to work with a building
in a different way and by then,
I had experienced hospitals
as a visiting artist
and I realized that patients
were not receiving any flowers.
So we gathered-- we, my
team of 80 and myself--
gathered 28,000
flowers and spread them
throughout the building in
a gesture of giving back
to the building
that which had been
missing since patients
in psychiatry rarely
receive flowers.
The project existed for four
days, not 28 minutes, four days
and afterwards, we returned all
the flowers which were potted--
none of them were cut--
to people behind bars.
So what I learned in public
art projects was became
crucial what then
happened which was
I wanted to connect with sites
and settings on a large scale,
but I didn't want to make
public art, I wanted to paint.
The next project
was a commission
for a very ugly concrete
wall in Western Massachusetts
on the campus of UMass Amherst.
And I proposed to
paint a large painting
and they were very disappointed.
They wanted something
spectacularly
strange and
interdisciplinary and I
said it's just going
to be a painting.
But the painting I
conceived of was the face
of an agricultural worker--
it used to be an
agricultural school--
that I found in the archives
doing my research there
and all I wanted to
do was to paint it
upside down so that you would
only see it in the water.
I did not tell anyone
how to use this work,
but wanted students
to discover it.
So it was called Just a
Rumor and the ducks that
live on this pond became my
collaborators because they
would wipe out the entire
painting by swimming
through it all the time.
There's one photo and this is it
that shows, oh, you can see it,
but it's a little dark, but
there are four ducks parked
in the face without swimming,
they're not pedaling,
and therefore you can see it.
They're just asleep
on the surface.
And then it froze and
we all forgot about it
and when spring came, it
thawed and we remembered
that the piece was still there.
And based on that, I
went back to my studio
again as a painter, as someone
who loves to draw and paint
with my pens and brushes,
and I felt what if I create
works that work with that
scale, but are using my most
beloved medium in another way.
And I was offered by
neuroscientists at Columbia
Medical School to collaborate
with them on a project that
uses eye tracking technology
that is attached to your pupil
so you don't use your
hands at all to draw,
but you use your eyes only.
And this is a drawing,
this is my first drawing
ever with my pupil only.
A camera records
where I'm looking
and each glance, every
direction my eyes make,
is recorded so I have to
be very careful and slow.
And this is a bicycle on the
right side going down hill--
you can maybe tell.
And based on that,
I decided what
if I create live drawings that
are truly touching the surfaces
I'm interested in,
those buildings
and sites and settings, for
example, a stage with dancers.
I was offered a
collaboration with dancers.
This is a draft for it and
then this was the actual dance.
The person, the dancer,
had taken a break
after a solo, laid
down, and I was
able to draw her
a blanket of lines
by using very high
tech projectors in New
York on a beautiful stage and it
was a live drawing performance.
So that's what I'm doing now.
I'm creating these drawings
that happen in actual time.
They're not canned,
they're not video.
This is an eye
tracking drawing that I
conceived for that Cooper
Hewitt Museum in New York.
This is the facade of it.
It was not realized
because of budget reasons,
but it was a drawing I did with
my eyes looking at a Man Ray
photograph that you all
know, with the eyelashes
and the tear.
And the straight
lines that come off it
are lines that are
made by my blinking.
And most recently,
these are smaller scale,
but still wall sized
live drawings transmitted
from New Orleans to Hanover,
New Hampshire for the Dartmouth
Biannual.
Every morning, I
made a drawing that
was wired over to Dartmouth and
it was projected onto this wall
very slowly.
So these are drawings created
for that wall in my absence
by me in a different state.
And we did 90 of these indoor
drawings-- one every day--
and then 12 for the outdoor
courtyard of the Hood Museum.
So here is one of them and
here is another and another.
This is a goat, of course.
And this is my
last slide for now,
a drawing of a hand created
live so it is moving.
So this is just a still of
that touching the surface
of the Hood Museum's back.
I am so grateful
to have been here.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
- Good afternoon
and thanks, as well,
for the invitation by
the Radcliffe Institute.
We are very honored to be here
and we will talk about nature,
technology, and culture.
- OK.
Our panel is called "Beyond the
Nature and Technology Divide."
And my first thought as an
architect hearing this title
was, if there is a dividing line
between nature and technology,
jumping over it is the
typical behavior for people
who have the profession of my
husband or climate engineers.
Because in their everyday
work, climate engineers
are measuring and
evaluating and interpreting
physical that is natural--
parametrics about
temperature, about light,
material, concluding technical
concepts out of them.
As soon as these concepts become
part of architecture or, even
more complex, part of urban
planning and these projects
get realized by
interdisciplinary teams,
culture pops up
as the term which
besides nature and technology.
These three terms became
the title of our talk
and the basis for our
thoughts and research.
To get familiar with the
urbanism in the global age,
we were tracing back
the history of settling
from today's megacities to
the very beginning of humanity
and human settlements.
We observed a specific
interdependence
of these three factors--
nature, technology,
and culture--
in every period of
settling and each factor
with different impact or
importance [? in ?] the period.
I don't know if
it's early for that.
Related to six billion
years of Earth's history
at a time 2.8 million years
since the genesis of humanity
is nearly nothing.
In the Pleistocene, 2.6 million
to 10,000 years before Christ,
is the first and very long
period of human settlement
and it's characterized
by a specific climate,
by the change between ice
ages and warmer periods.
At that time,
settlement was totally
based on nature and
natural conditions.
This cave is called Hohle Fels.
It's in southern Germany.
It was inhabited for a very long
time and remains of mammoths,
spears, and white horses were
found and the very first known
piece of art, this Venus, which
is about 35,000 years old.
It's like this,
carved from ivory
and a great cultural
contribution.
After the last ice age,
climate stayed nearly constant
from 10,000 before Christ to
let's say 1800 after Christ.
This period is called Holocene
and the climate conditions
were very good for a
widespread cultural blooming.
Nearly everything
we call culture
was developed in this period--
writing, architecture, a lot
of new science, knowledge.
It's no accident that all
the high culture developed
in this period in Egypt, all
over the world-- in China,
in the Middle East, and so on.
This diagram shows the
Holocene temperature profile
I already mentioned.
After the long
period with ice ages,
you can see that in the
Holocene, about 10,000 years,
temperature only decreases
for half a degree.
And nowadays, we expect a
man-made temperature change
increase between 1.5 and
3 degrees within 50 years.
This picture of our
illuminated planet
represents the period
we are living in now.
It's the Anthropocene, where
humans and man-made technology
determine the form,
the happenings,
and the evolution on Earth.
Every light spot represents a
big city and the light pattern
as a whole for me
gives an idea about all
issues of global urbanism,
about population explosion,
about energy consumption, about
density, about neighborhoods
if we are so close together
and if we have so many,
about the demand
of land and food,
about scale, about
[? heimat-- ?]
it's typical German word
about responsibility,
identity maybe, individuality.
Now, while the
previous periods like
starting with the
Pleistocene, which
durated 2.8 million years
or 2.4 million years
and then the Holocne
around 12,000 years,
finally our Anthropocene at the
moment is like 200 years old.
And it's called the time
of the big accelerations,
looking on development of
population on this planet,
material consumption, but
then as well the consequences
in respect of losing nature,
in this case other people
or created nature, but as well
kind of increasing pollution
effects that we are created
by our technology applying
to be able to live in
any spot on this planet.
There are consequences
out of it, a side of it
that, for example, here
a picture of Beijing,
the lower one represents
[? Beijing ?] of around 5%
of the year.
85% of the year, the
air quality in Beijing
is described as unhealthy
or even hazardous.
And alone in China, they lose
like three million people
a year just by air pollution.
So [INAUDIBLE] it looks
like biotechnology
and our kind of leftovers
from our technology
we're kind of slowly
poisoning ourselves.
As a side effect,
we know and Anya
mentioned it, kind of
compared it to the Holocene
was 0.5 degrees
over 10,000 years,
we are now in this
kind of 100 years
increase already in
certain spots temperature
of this planet by 2.5 degrees.
And then coming back to
the first presentation,
in this case water will be our
big problem because suddenly,
and I think we can't solve
it probably with an estuary,
because [? interestingly ?]
now looking on this one,
we are what we describe
nature now suddenly
will endanger culture.
Because looking on all the
cultural cities along the East
Coast of North America,
they will be all gone.
So this in mind, but it's
not only endangering us,
it's as well endangering any
life on this planet, nature.
[? Like ?] nature, this
is kind of the birds,
the [? found ?] birds reduction
just looking over the last 20
years in this case in Germany,
looking back by the intensity
of our agriculture.
Increasing the intensity
of our aquaculture,
we are cutting down the
population of birds.
And there have been
effects kind of looking
on it that like in 2007, they
started to introduce kind
of bio gas in Germany, which
increased kind of a lot of corn
growing in Germany,
intensifying,
creating big areas but kind of
cutting down the last refuges
for nature.
Now, what is interesting
on this one, which
describes the kind of
status of the habitats
of the different ecosystems,
just looking on three of them,
the ocean and the
cropland and the urban.
For the ocean, 85% of
the species in the ocean,
we don't know what is
their status because we
unknown their habits.
What is interesting now looking
comparing cropland and urban,
and I think this is now quite
interesting for our discussion
on urban, that it looks
like nature in urban
can find niches to
survive compared
to intensive used
agricultural land
because there is a large
diversity in cities
and in natural
islands in the city.
There are no fertilizers
and there's no hunting.
These are [INAUDIBLE],
which I'm glad to say
there are a lot of
them and some of them
are really almost unbelievable.
These wild pigs
which live in Rome,
I heard, and the biggest
nightingale population
in Germany is in Berlin.
The biggest hare population
lives in Stuttgart city center,
pumas in Los Angeles,
raccoons and foxes
I think in almost every
city of the world meanwhile.
What I found interesting
is that animals that
used to be afraid of people,
they are coming so close.
This is a kind of adaption
which is another example.
These are the [? storks. ?]
Only a few decades ago,
they left their territory if
somebody builds a small road
and divides it into two pieces.
In a very short time
later, nowadays storks
have adapted to modern
living conditions.
They have even changed
their migration routes
and a lot of North
European storks
don't fly to Africa anymore and
spend the winter on waste dumps
in Spain eating leftovers.
This is an example
from Stuttgart,
where they found a population
of a protected species of lizard
which settled down
and used holding
tracks off the main station.
And as the German railway
now wants to expand and build
something on this
site, they really
have a problem because following
the German law on nature
[? conservation, ?]
they have to organize
a complete resettlement
program for these lizards.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
OK.
So to be honest, I have a quite
romantic relation to nature.
And I wish I could believe
in a different nature.
I am not so sure.
But these niches and
the ability to adapt,
that gives me some kind of hope.
And I would say that
just because there's
a lack of space and land, I
think that nature will totally
change and the scale
will totally change.
There really will be
only spots of nature.
There are other people, wise
people like Stephen Hawking,
who are much less optimistic.
And he suggested to seek
space, somewhere else.
- Yeah.
Which is an interesting
position to think about,
that after a six billion
year life of this planet,
we messed it up in 200 years
and then escape to outer space.
But there is hope.
We think technology and
nature can feed each other.
And starting on one of our first
examples, this is Masdar City,
we already saw a picture today.
We worked with
Foster and Partners
on the master plan for this
first carbon neutral city
in the Middle East.
Now, what is the identity?
How we typically describe
a place of Abu Dhabi,
you typically get
northwesterly winds.
These northwesterly winds
come over the Arabic Gulf,
which in summertime heats
up to 35 degrees Celsius, so
around 110 degrees Fahrenheit.
So it's very warm.
Warm and humid the wind
comes from the sea.
It's pretty warm
so you are exposed
and you have high sun
kind of irradiation.
So living in the desert, your
air temperature reaching up
to 46 degrees Celsius,
even the felt temperature
would be even much more.
Now, looking at Abu Dhabi today,
at urban life in Abu Dhabi,
there is no urban life
during most of the year
because it's too hot.
And to cross a 35-meter-wide
avenue in Abu Dhabi,
it's dangerous
because you may not
reach the other side because
it's exposing you to around
150 degrees Fahrenheit.
So our approach was that
instead of this heat island,
we recognized from
big mega cities
like Tokyo nowadays is six
to eight degrees warmer
than outside, we said,
the approach for this city
should be to create instead of
a heat island a cold island.
So what are the
technologies coming back
too much denser cities, to
cities which are self-shading,
which are using natural
resources like the night wind
to cool down, to orient the
streets depending on the wind
direction that the
warm winds of the day
are not coming into [INAUDIBLE]
which curve to the east, where
the cool night wind which
is 100 degree Fahrenheit,
comes in at nighttime but
allows the city to ventilate?
That's where the basis
of this master plan.
And if you look on it, you
see these green fingers
going through, but
the very dense city
kind of allowing that the city
stays 10 degrees below outside.
And these were our
real-time measurements
like two summers ago.
Outside in the desert up
to 50 degrees Celsius.
In the city we could reach
this kind of 10 degree.
What is interesting,
in this case
talking about the city
as a kind of organism
which reacts with the
help of the wind tower
to be ventilated at nighttime.
So these [INAUDIBLE],
these concrete elements
along the facades,
they collect, they
store the night cool
and help the city
to survive over the next day
so we could ensure that there
is an urban life even happening
during the warm periods
of the year.
And concluding in respect
of energy and consumption,
this kind of 50,000 square meter
which we realized consumed only
20% of what a typical building
in Abu Dhabi would do,
still allowing-- and this is
the infrared picture on the left
side--
to realize cool temperatures.
Now, jumping to
our second project,
it's an exhibition
pavilion for Austria
on the Expo in Milan 2015,
where the overall theme was
food in the cities.
And the intention of Klaus
[? Loenhart, ?] the architect
from Austria, was
creating in [INAUDIBLE]
a piece of an Austrian mountain
forest in the exhibition
as kind of the Austrian
pavilion, which
by better air, by low
noise, by good smell,
by comfortable temperature,
would attract people
to be confronted with
the benefits of nature
in a kind of a
sealed environment.
That was the kind of diagrams.
We planted around 12,600 plants
in around 560 square meters.
They have around
45,000 square meters
of leaves, which are evaporating
humidity and cooling down
the space.
We are adding misting systems
and increased the velocity
in the space so people felt
quite comfortable in the space.
This is the verification.
So we could, comparable
to Abu Dhabi,
reduce the temperature compared
to outside in the range
around 10 degrees Celsius,
kind of an impression how
you would kind of benefit
from this microclimate
in this space.
And last year, I [INAUDIBLE] to
participate at the Architecture
Bienalle, which was titled
"Reporting from the Front"
and many thoughts popped
up, but finally we
decided to do an installation
about the power of nature.
Right from the
start, I had in mind
to reproduce natural
phenomena because I
think somehow it's a kind
of collective experience.
We are all deeply
and emotionally
touched watching the sea,
discovering a rainbow,
finding a falling star,
or something like that.
We chose to showcase visible
sunrise, so-called [INAUDIBLE],
or more poetically, and
[? just ?] [? ask ?] among
other things because there is
a connection to a real research
project [INAUDIBLE] did for
[INAUDIBLE] for the new Louvre
in Abu Dhabi.
We wanted to do an exhibit
out of such a phenomenon
by moving it from the
outside to the inside
here in the Arsenale in Venice.
And we wanted to just
study these emotions
and really because of
time pressure, I'm sorry,
we wanted to do it
quite literally and out
of its elements.
And we wanted people to get very
close to it, closer than ever,
and ideally ineractive somehow.
In nature, these rays can only
be seen if leaves or clouds are
blocking the light and
create a high brightness
contrast in the visual field.
And the light has to
be scattered by little
like micro particles in the air,
the so-called Tyndall effect
In a long, long series
of tests, [INAUDIBLE]
managed to create this
atmosphere indoors.
Despite converging on
mostly every picture,
sun rays are parallel
shafts of sunlight
and it's just phenomenal the
perspective of the observer
that we always think
they are converging.
There are now
people interacting.
We can just go on.
And creating another
bunch of lines,
creating another bunch of--
While planning
this installation,
dealing with the power of
nature a lot of questions
arose about the independence of
nature in human kind and so on.
We engraved some of
them into a wooden plate
of the installation.
These questions are all about
nature, about technology,
about culture, and
somehow they are also
about urbanism in a global age.
- Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- So thank you all.
I think just listening to
the three presentations,
it seems to me I
was coming to this
and I was kind of expecting
this was the designer panel,
[? you ?] can
design an art panel,
and then it turns out
into the wetlands panel.
Somehow the ducks tied together.
But was what we hear
across the table here
is very different kind of ways
of elaborating the relationship
between man and nature.
I hear first this kind
of alternate nature
as a relationship always
between settlement
and the physical
environment; I hear
this idea of nature
and technology
together as both
kind of observers
and as participants in
the kind of intervention,
in the case of Ana;
and then I hear
this kind of idea
of the Anthropocene
and the kind of parallel between
the niches and adaptation
for the natural, but also then
this kind of use of technology
to deliberately alter or
control natural effects.
So in a way, using technology
to deflect the natural
or deflect from natural forces.
Ana's kind of forcing
it into participation
with the kind of cultural
and physical environments
that are at play and
Anya and Matthias
are using it to deliberately
as a kind of tool
act against or with these
kind of physical forces.
And so within
that, I would say I
would ask first
of all of you, is
that kind of role of technology
kind of calling into question
the idea of nature
for you, or is it
kind of allowing you to create
a more specific or firm concept
of the natural in
order to kind of build
your own work from that?
Is it a calling into
question or is it
kind of a strengthening
of a natural concept?
- I would understand
it in our approach
that typically, we are using
technology not to ignore.
Because the typical
settlement in the Middle
East is ignoring nature
that in Abu Dhabi
you were not able to live
because there was just too hot.
So people migrated from Abu
Dhabi to Al Ain in the summer,
lived six months in Al
[INAUDIBLE] in desert,
where it was the same
hot but not as humid,
and then in fall they
came back for pearl diving
to live six months in Abu
Dhabi and migrate back.
So they adapted.
But by inventing the
chiller technology,
we kind of defined we are
creating a city here where
normally nature doesn't
make it possible.
So our approach was
now understanding
that we should not fight
nature, but in [? a sense ?]
we support natural giving.
There is this 30
degree cold wind
which can help the cities to
survive even at daytime if we
don't ignore in Abu
Dhabi master plan it's
a 100% copy of
Manhattan city to Abu
Dhabi with 75-meter-wide
avenues where
you are just roasted by
crossing the street at daytime.
- Well, actually, I
mean, if I may just
instigate perhaps a discussion.
I mean, what I
found fascinating,
actually, om your
presentation I think
is this notion, actually,
of nature adapting.
It was interesting,
actually, your observation
that nature adapts.
Now, that's a very
unusual observation--
but I should say it's very
revealing of a certain--
I guess it's carried in the term
Anthropocene to some extent,
that we have taken
the position actually
that humankind actually
has changed the planet.
But then you're also saying
that nature is adapting to us.
I mean, my question
is, actually,
where are you really situating
nature in this whole thing?
So when you talk
about the desert
and you're talking
about inhabiting
the desert, actually,
and then moving out,
I mean, you're talking
about people moving out
and sort of that this
is uninhabitable but now
it has become [? inhabitable ?]
through Foster's design
in this manner.
It sort of raises
for me actually
very profound questions actually
on your measures of comfort,
your measures actually--
I mean, everything about
nature is taking its measure
from the human, and
that is to some extent
the Anthropocene, the other
side of the Anthropocene.
I mean, so when you're
talking about defining an era,
you're also defining the era
as defined by man, as it were.
And man is a peculiar man.
I mean, he's a man
who is actually
working with
technology that we take
for granted in a certain way.
Now, I come from another part
of the world where technology
hasn't been imposed, so
I find it interesting,
actually, when you
sort of present science
as actually moving
in a trajectory,
as revealing actually an
Earth of a certain kind.
But I'm wondering, actually,
whether you're defining nature
to fit your technology and
not the other way around.
- No, definitely.
Definitely not because we are--
I think this is the
typical way technology
was used in definitely
the last 100 years,
that in a certain way, it
allowed us to ignore nature.
Let's put it like this.
And a little part of nature
at certain points can adapt
to our changed environment, but
most of the sorts of animals
and plants, they will just
die out because in these kind
of inhabitable areas,
they cannot survive.
Now, if we talk about an
adaptation, it's right.
At certain points, what we did
in Masdar City is until now,
there is no urban living
half of a year-- six
to nine months-- because between
eight o'clock in the morning
and ten o'clock in
the evening, you
don't go out because
it's too hot.
So the city is dead.
What is a city
without street life?
So allowing, then,
in such a climate
to allow people to be
living, as well, outdoors,
I think is a big
improvement, but not
by using technology
but by understanding
the natural forces
and supporting
the natural forces to help
us to get this temperature.
There is no chiller, it's
just the outside wind.
But at daytime we keep
it out and at nighttime
we bring it in.
And it's not our invention.
If you go to Sicily and look
on the old medieval cities,
they are exactly
using this technology.
But we forgot it.
By inventing the chiller and
the fan, we just got rid of it.
- I think it's interesting
that on some level,
the design ends of the
table are fundamentally
opposed in their approach
but the results end up
being sort of similar.
Is the cold island really so
different from the high ground
and low ground, other
than that maybe you
would just want
everyone to go inside
during the hot part of the day?
But up against that,
I think Ana's approach
is very different in
that you're freely
deploying the natural or
the non-human, the human,
the technological that
can all appear kind of one
after the other because the
actual ultimate question is
about a kind of relationship
amongst them all, but also
to the end of understanding a
public space that includes them
all, including the non-human.
What would you say?
When you hear the
kind of debate here,
where do you feel like your
practice fits into that?
- I think I'm perfectly
seated between you two.
My role is not to
solve problems.
My role is maybe to
create brief problems
and then resolve them
in a playful way.
I don't have to use
technology to serve,
but I can use
technology to play.
It's an active play.
And to hopefully not
just play, but to engage
reengage when
engagement was broken.
- I think that kind of question
of engagement here is maybe
something that still
unites across the panel,
that everyone is deploying a
kind of an idea of an ecology,
if ecology means just a
system between the human
and the non-human presences in a
kind of coherent or sustainable
constellation, that everyone
is deploying an ecology
as a cultural strategy.
It's still answerable
back to culture.
Even if you're trying to
deflect back and allow
the natural environment in, it's
still answerable to some level
to allow the kind of
ongoing presence of culture,
but that may be to inform
what that presence might be.
And I think that--
- Let me clarify one thing.
I mean, I think I
mean, to argue actually
with the sense of where
technology and nature are
relative to one another.
I mean, it's not to oppose.
I mean, I'm not you.
I mean, I think
I'm distinguishing
a whole paradigm of
thought, actually, that
is driving your assumptions
here and just pointing out
one possibility,
actually, whereby
I think there is a certain--
so in other words, Ana,
you're not sort of situated
between anything.
I mean, it's not like
I'm on the other side.
So it's just-- the
issue is this, I think.
To look at technology
as some way by which
humans relate to nature
or means by which--
it's a kind of an
instrumental sort of--
I mean, it's a means by which
you relate to your environment.
If I look at it
like that, I mean,
I think for me what is
critical is actually
how you define environment.
And I think I think how
you come to terms then
with that space
between then follows,
I mean in terms of
actually a space of design.
So when I see you actually sort
of [? fuzzing ?] this thing up,
there's a certain
measure by which
you're defining both
technology and nature to suit
a certain mode of designing.
And what I am
suggesting is actually
that design plays a
more fundamental role
in taking charge of that
definition by which you
have sort of made it convenient
to act in a particular way.
You made it convenient
for yourself to act.
And that to some extent--
I mean, for me coming from
a colonized world wherein
I find knowledges have been
destroyed, ways of being have
been destroyed, I am called to
a certain humility, actually,
in my understanding
of the space of design
and a certain reflection,
actually, on what design can
do, actually, not just to
promote the singular measures
that I come to the table.
But to sort of see that there
are other possibilities,
there are other ways by
which people [? live ?]
and maybe we have
not understood them
except on our own measures.
So when you talk
about going indoors,
I don't think that's
the answer, actually.
Just because I'm not out to
that doesn't mean I'm indoors.
I mean, there's a whole
other measure by which
I come to understanding.
And so maybe
indoors and outdoors
is not a concept
that I deal with.
I mean, we saw Sooni's--
when you spoke of there's no
inside and outside in Mumbai,
that the person on the
street, no inside and outside,
that sense of actually
the fact that there
is no indoor and outdoor
in certain places.
How do you deal with that?
You know what am saying?
It s your measure falls
off the table when
you don't have
the context for it
or you don't have
the ground for it.
- Yeah, but OK.
I think you have
to differentiate.
We move indoors,
this was a measure
for this art installation
in a certain way
to get people exposed
or in a certain way
give people the
possibility to experience
kind of unnatural phenomena.
In this case, it
was a rain of light;
six years ago we
did a cloud indoors.
So I think understanding
the physics,
we are able to reproduce
even indoors partially
some natural aspects.
But we would never define--
I would not see us using
technology to define nature.
Because I think the point
which we are facing today
is that technology has
led us that at the moment,
my understanding is that nature
is endangering our culture.
And probably, as I
said, the estuaries
will not help to get the
seven meters of rising ocean
when all the ice is melting.
- Right.
- Let's keep this argument going
on as responses to questions
from the crowd.
So let's open it up.
- Thank you.
Can you hear me?
Funny, I landed in Abu Dhabi--
my name is Johnny [INAUDIBLE].
I landed in Abu Dhabi
on the 4th of July
and they gave me a
car at the airport
and I couldn't put my
hands on the steering
so I immediately realized that
this is not a habitable place.
But I was stuck there
for three years.
But my question is that I
think between the paradigms
that you're describing,
I'm a marketing background
and usually, we find out
the success of a project
by the market.
So we let the market speak
and then when we hear it say,
OK, that worked or not.
And my understanding is Masdar
is a complete failure thus far,
with the billions of
dollars spent on it--
thus far, so I don't know.
And my question is, do you
feel that the project Masdar
City is a success?
- OK.
I will say
thermodymanically, it's
a success, the
50,000 square meters
which were built because
the urban approach to create
a cold island could be proven.
Economically, interesting-wise,
the whole exercise
or the whole target of Masdar
was to invest $22 billion
to build the first
carbon neutral city.
At the end when then the
economic crisis of 2008 even
reached the Middle
East, the sheikhs
didn't have the
strength to stand it
and they gave it to developers.
And what we see now, and
this is very interesting,
you can Google up the new
master plan of Masdar.
They introduced now avenues
which run from the northwest
to the southeast.
81-meter-wide, even wider
than in the existing city.
So they will look at the
hot winds into the city.
So I see it like this.
OK, there's a lot to learn
out of this approach.
Certain technologies or
certain approaches, concept
worked, but at the end it
struggled on the limits
of the economical system.
And even the people which
at the beginning said,
we are spending money
to show the world
that we which are the worst
guys because we have the biggest
ecological footprint as
a country of the world,
we can show that we can build
this first carbon neutral city,
they didn't have the strength
to keep their own expectation
and they failed.
So I wouldn't see
this as a big failure
because of the consequences.
Masdar certainly
initiated such a lot.
And I think this is as
well we had even when
I was teaching at the GSD,
we had a governor from Texas
there in 2007.
It was just not even a year old.
He was totally surprised.
He knew about Masdar.
So the world heard about Masdar
and the knowledge and the news
was spread.
And we were always
asking and even
talking to marketing
people, what
was the secret of this success?
And the secret of
this success is
there was somebody brave to say,
we are looking for a solution
and not just talking
about the problem.
So Masdar at least set
up an example or a try
to solve it instead of just
lamenting on the problem.
I think this is the
biggest success.
- I really appreciate you saying
that technology is endangering
us because with all the
gizmos coming out every year,
people have been
lulled into thinking
that that's the answer.
We might run out of fuel at some
point for some things, which
brings me to Dilip.
I loved, loved what you did.
I can't wait to read the
book or see the program
or go to the movie or
whatever happens with that.
One question about high
ground, low ground.
In thee cities that are
talking about resilience
and sustainability, at
least on the east coast,
I hear that the
priority for going high
is like making the highway
which is next to the water
even higher.
In your diagram, is going high
human access, living areas
connected to living
areas, or is it
the transportation, the trucking
corridors, the whatever?
And I wonder in
the break if we can
see the [? Trans ?]
solar slides flipped
the way we saw Sooni's
spectacular amount
of information put together.
- One of the issues
I think that come up
with what we call the fingers
of high ground as a solution--
I sort of hesitate
to use that term--
but perhaps as an
alternate approach is
that there is a particularity.
There's a particularity
to them actually depending
on where they are that defines.
So the two projects
that we did in Norfolk,
I mean one was actually
next to the Naval yard.
I mean, it was on
the Elizabeth River.
So it was an
infrastructural, it was
where [? real ?]
meets sea, as it were,
[? real ?] meets the Elizabeth.
And so it had particular
conditions, actually,
by which people were.
There was a treatment
plant there.
And we took on
issues that were very
particular to the
treatment plant.
When there's a
hurricane, for example,
they sort of release
sewage into the ocean.
So we said, why don't we
design barges, actually,
the extension of fingers
to actually then also
dissipate waves, et
cetera, et cetera.
So what I'm saying
is that there's
a particularity to each finger.
But that is actually
on the issues
that we're facing from the sea.
But then there are
community issues.
We found that in
Norfolk, for example,
that the people actually
living on the sea
were not that endangered
as people living inland
because rain had nowhere to go.
So the people who were drowning
or in danger of [INAUDIBLE]
were actually inland.
So it was actually
between rain and tide
that we were designing.
So yes.
The complexity builds up.
But I think that that
is the beauty, actually,
of working with a particular
[? on the east coast. ?]
While we can make a
kind of general comment,
actually, on turning
the coast, it really
requires very grassroots sort
of activity in terms of--
and we've tried,
actually, to do that.
But it really needs--
that people are willing to
change governance, actually,
so governance structures
in the Chesapeake.
And that is happening slowly.
so we are still in
conversation with the Army
Corps of Engineers, actually,
working in that area.
And we're dying to
actually do a pilot project
where we can actually review
the diversity of these things.
I'm not quite sure if I'm
answering your question, am I?
- I just think would
be awfully interesting
if all these towns
in jeopardy would
have maps around the town
showing the high ground, low
ground.
Unless people know
what to-- this
is a different way of thinking,
although in New Orleans
they figured out pretty fast
where the high ground was,
which were the overpasses.
But it would just be
interesting to remap one's world
into high ground, low ground.
And it doesn't
rely on technology,
it relies on nature helping
us, which is grade, elevation.
- Can I take a little more time?
I hope-- I don't want to be
taking time from the others.
I just want to raise a point.
I mean, one of the beautiful
things about thinking
about high ground, low
ground versus a coastline
is that when we read the
surface of the earth,
actually, in terms of urban
and rural, for example,
we are seeing
actually cities, which
is a question, actually,
for the symposium,
actually, which I sort of
find a little problematic.
Because when we
use the term urban,
we are actually using it
exclusively and excluding
things that are outside of it.
So when one refers to the
desert, et cetera, et cetera,
one is actually
positioning it outside.
And I wonder sometimes what
one is positioning outside
of the city.
But that reading,
actually, where
the city has been given
a measure to things
is very different from a
middle ground, for example.
And so if I actually
do maps that
work with drawing
the middle ground out
as the agency with
which we work,
you get a completely different
structuring, actually,
of the surface of the
Earth, as compared
to working with cities
that you can then
talk about as successes, which
is to me extremely problematic.
But I don't want to get
into that discussion
because it all depends on how
you define the problem in order
to fit the solution.
- The solution-- I think one
of the problems here is that
if you look at the projections--
there are maps, by the way,
available showing what sea
level rise would do to coastal
cities, but yet money is
pouring into [? Seaport ?]
or into Miami Beach on
the premise, I suspect,
that by the time disaster
hits in 2050 or 2070,
we'll have our money, the
original owners have sold it,
if they even can sell it.
But looking up the
heat issue, if you
look at the projections
for the Arabian Peninsula
with [? wet ?] bulb
temperatures, by 2050 or 2060,
there won't be very
cool winds coming off
in the humidity ranges needed.
So trying to design
in today's parameters
but ignoring 25 or 30 years
out, let alone 50 or 100.
At one time you could
walk from Boston Light
during the glacial maximum all
the way out to the George's
Bank.
70 meters is a lot to
overcome and you're not
going to do it by trying to
imitate Dutch technology.
It will buy a few years, but
that's all it's going to buy.
So I guess my
question of the panel
is, when are we going
to start looking
at reasonable projections,
rather than sort of work
on these very narrow
timeframes of 20 or 30 years
and ignore the fact
that it's going
to be a lot different
by the time I'm dead
and everybody in
this room is dead
but our children and
our grandchildren
will have to face a
whole different world?
- I would see we are
looking on the next years
because politically, the
decisions we do the next years,
they will determine the next
50 and the next 100 years.
Because the time is so
late that our decisions are
so critical that expecting that
this might be solved though
the technology in 10 or
15 years, that's too late.
And I think this is the
dangerous kind of performance
or habit of climate change,
that you don't feel it
before it really
strikes and then it's
too late because the
system is so big.
And this is nature.
So this has been, again
back to the discussion
that in a certain way,
we messed that up.
And the question is, are
we able to bring it back
to a certain performance?
I think the planet will
survive because it survived
other waves of temperature.
The question is if the
human period will survive.
- All right.
I think we can wrap
it up with that.
No.
Please.
[APPLAUSE]